it's a genre of gunfights fisticuffs and
car chases so fans are expecting
excitement and fast from costumed gangs
gathering in the streets to clandestine
murders that'll chill the spines of the
coldest killers these are some of the
greatest opening scenes in action movie
history meet the Warriors in the
Warriors director walter hill wastes no
time in setting up the movie stakes from
the very first frame
everybody says that Cyrus is the one and
only
I think we better go have a look for us
so the way Hill drops exposition during
the Centro is incredibly economical a
big meeting is about to go down and we
get a view of a subway map to show us
the Warriors are about to find
themselves far from their Coney Island
turf and as our ragtag heroes plan their
Odyssey to the Bronx were introduced to
a wide and unusual variety of gangs all
on similar journeys in just six minutes
we've met our main characters we
understand the stakes and we've got a
feel for this fantasy world so when the
truce is broken and things get crazy
we're already primed for what's going
down tomb raiding it could easily be
argued that Raiders of the Lost Ark
features the greatest opening sequence
of all time after the Paramount logo
dissolves into an actual Mountain which
is a nice enough touch in itself
Spielberg plunges viewers into a
veritable love letter to old-timey
serials and Saturday morning adventures
and at the center of it all is that
first reveal of the movie's enigmatic
hero
but it's when John steps into that
Hidden Temple that you really know
Raiders is going to be special he's
faced with one setback after another
including that iconic rolling Boulder
and even when Jones makes his way
outside he finds himself face-to-face
with his arch rival and an army of very
unhappy natives and while this classic
opening is nonstop action it teaches us
everything we need to know about Jones
he's a man of action and a problem
solver he's a little cocky and every so
often he screws up royally
most importantly this guy can face
arrows arachnids pistols and deep dark
pits and nothing at all can faze him
well almost nothing
there's a big snake in my exam kicking
off it's easy to forget nowadays but
when the matrix was released in 1999 it
quickly became a cultural force to be
reckoned with and it all began with a
kick the movie opens with the wall of
digital rain and a mysterious
conversation between two unseen people
about somebody called the one that's
when the cops show up
moving down an abandoned apartment
hallway and busting down a door on the
other side sits Trinity clad in shiny
black leather and ready for a showdown
we don't know why the police water but
we quickly realized they're never going
to catch her
[Music]
audiences were hooked from scene one and
then with chaski zero a major debt to
carry on Moss for kicking their film off
in the right way a fresh angle Hot Fuzz
works on many levels it's a brilliant
comedy a slasher film and a fantastic
satire of Michael Bay style action
movies but it's also a solid action
flick that revels in the joys of the
genre it Lampoon's Sergeant Nicholas
angel on the other hand absolutely hates
all that action movie foolishness played
too serious perfection by Simon Pegg
angel has no time for fun and games from
his first appearance through to the
ensuing rapid-fire montage of angel
cleaning up the streets of London it's
clear that the man is all about bringing
down bad guys properly with a few
injuries along the way and the sustain
through injuries in the line of duty
most recently in December when wounded
by a man dressed as father Christmas the
whole opening montage is a fantastic set
up for the kicker in which angel is
unceremoniously kicked off the force for
being too perfect however you spin this
there's one thing you haven't taken into
a cat
and that's what the team is gonna make
of this death in Prague a lot of fans
were skeptical about the casting of
Daniel Craig as James Bond so it was
crucial that Casino Royale made a good
first impression he was also essential
that the movie let audiences know they
were in store for something new this was
bond in the age of Jason Bourne the
movie needed a killer opening shot in
gloriously cold black-and-white Casino
Royale opening tells the story of bonds
first two kills as an mi6 agent we watch
as he savagely destroys an enemy spy
beating the dude to a pulp before
drowning him in a bathroom sink Thank
You Celia did he this vicious murder is
intercut with the scene set in Prague in
which bond confronts a traitorous
section chief although he finds himself
on the wrong end of a gun it soon
becomes clear that he's a spy who can
think two steps ahead you needn't worry
second is
[Music]